a liberal judge has won her race for the
Wisconsin Supreme Court and this gives
liberals control of the Wisconsin
Supreme Court for the first time in 15
years now of course we are going to be
talking about the fact that the failed
former president Donald Trump was
arrested but I wanted to start with this
today because some good things did
actually happen yesterday we also got a
progressive mayor in Chicago which we're
going to talk about we'll talk about the
Trump stuff but let's start here this
has been a hugely right-wing Supreme
Court in Wisconsin abortion rights are
in question
gerrymandering related issues executed
by Republicans are a major issue that
may indeed come before the Wisconsin
Supreme Court in the future and so this
is a very good piece of news the New
York Times report liberal wins Wisconsin
court race in Victory for abortion
rights backers Janet pritasowitz
prevailed in the state's highly
consequential contest for the Supreme
Court which will now be likely to
reverse the state's abortion ban huge
and end the use of gerrymandered
legislative Maps this is very very good
news the defeated conservative was
Daniel Kelly
former Wisconsin Supreme Court Justice
who was trying to get his way back onto
the bench with more than 95 percent of
the votes counted by Wednesday morning
this morning judge pertazowitz led by 11
points which is a very big margin of
Victory now there were all these things
about oh well she crushed him no she
didn't she's only up by 11. understand
that in a state like Wisconsin which is
as divided as it is an 11 Point Victory
in this race is quite a walloping quite
frankly I don't know how else to say it
a whole bunch of money was spent on this
race and at the end of the day the
60-year-old pretazowitz is going to now
make this the first liberal Supreme
Court
in 15 years in the state of Wisconsin I
want to play for you a little bit of the
disgusting concession speech from Kelly
this is this is a uh you know it this is
a tantrum sort of concession speech
attacking his opponent take a look at
this brings me no joy to say this
I wish that in a circumstance like this
I would be able to concede to a worthy
opponent whoa
but I do not have a worthy opponent to
which I can concede wow
this was the most deeply deceitful
dishonorable despicable campaign I have
ever seen Run for the courts is he
talking about himself
it was truly beneath contempt anyway so
a very bitter concession speech there
from Daniel Kelly but at the end of the
day we've been talking about this this
is what happens when you exist in a Maga
bubble and you pick candidates based not
on what is actually going on in the
country but based on what you think is
going on based on your tiny little
bubble and we saw this in Kansas when it
came to the abortion vote and they
decided to run an anti-abortion
extremist in Wisconsin and Wisconsin is
more Progressive than Kansas even Kansas
voted to defend abortion rights so it's
not crazy to look at these results and
say yeah that sort of makes sense you
shouldn't have run the anti-abortion nut
um also you know 2020 was rigged isn't
great the same guy Daniel Kelly advised
the state Republican party in crafting
one of those fake elector schemes to try
to get Donald Trump the electoral votes
from Wisconsin rather than Joe Biden we
saw that that costs them a lot and uh
this is this is what happens so when you
look back at the Wisconsin Supreme Court
you see a bunch of very right-wing
decisions during the covet era the right
wing the then right-wing Wisconsin
Supreme Court
struck down the stay-at-home order from
the governor Tony Evers similar orders
all over the country it was just what
was being done they struck that down in
July of 2020 the right-wing Wisconsin
Supreme Court blocked a plan to delay
the primary because of the pandemic
something that was done in other states
it wasn't really like the biggest deal
and then they struck down a mask mandate
uh as well and again Most states had
these at that point in time eventually
they went away so this is hugely
consequential consequential we are going
to see this decision
so first of all when you when you see a
court change hands uh you don't always
know the full consequences because you
don't yet know what may come before that
court but we know that when it comes to
the abortion ban almost certainly this
is a court that's going to have to deal
with that when you look at uh
gerrymandering almost certainly this is
a court that would deal with that and
importantly we don't yet know what's
going to happen in November of 2024.
if you said well it's Connecticut I
could tell you with certainty this is
not going to be a consequential state in
determining who is the president
Connecticut's just not going to be that
Wisconsin is increasingly a flash point
in the we are going to try to steal it
Narrative of the right and so the
Supreme Court of Wisconsin might
actually play a role in 2024 in ensuring
now that we know who's on the court in
ensuring that the candidate who received
the most votes actually gets the
electoral vote so hugely consequential
great news out of Wisconsin also great
news out of Chicago let's talk about
that next